se espera que sea el día de Acción de
Gracias más concurrido de los últimos
tres años ya que los estadounidenses
vuelven a viajar en cantidades
comparables a las prepandémicas el
martes se registraron 48.000 vuelos
programados pero los estadounidenses
parecen estar cambiando sus patrones de
viaje y espaciando sus desplazamientos
no he tenido ningún problema hasta ahora
esta mañana todo ha ido bastante bien
sin pérdida de maletas nada
hoy no hemos facturado ninguna maleta
Así que ha sido muy fácil sin retrasos Y
eso que nos preocupaba el tiempo así que
hemos tomado el vuelo más temprano
porque los vuelos fueron cancelados las
últimas semanas
en Nueva York se dieron los últimos
toques a uno de los momentos más
destacados de la celebraciones anuales
el desfile de acción de gracias de
Macy's el evento organizado por los
grandes almacenes se acerca a su
Centenario y tanto los neoyorquinos como
los turistas están recuperando el tiempo
perdido Y aprovechando al máximo el
clima festivo
es un día maravilloso ya habíamos hecho
esto en el pasado cuando era un bebé y
hacía mucho frío así que es agradable
estar aquí con un tiempo más cálido
disfrutando de los globos y de la
tradición de Acción de Gracias estamos
aquí para ver los globos por primera vez
somos neoyorquinos nacidos y criados
pero me hacía ilusión traer a mi hija
por primera vez fue un día precioso
como he dicho siempre estuvo en mi lista
de deseos lo he visto todos los años en
la televisión desde que era pequeña
las festividades se han visto opacadas
por dos tiroteos masivos en la última
semana en Colorado y Virginia lo que ha
llevado las autoridades de Nueva York a
desplegar seguridad adicional para el
desfile de este año